Життю Корінни можна позаздрити
Соціальна працівниця з Берліна отримує гроші просто так
без необхідності працювати
Щомісяця протягом року їй перераховуватимуть
тисячу євро як безумовний базовий дохід
Це розслабляє, дає мені відчуття свободи, можливість робити те, що я хочу
самій ухвалювати рішення і керувати своїм життям
Ніхто не вказує мені, що робити,
ніхто не тисне на мене
немає тягара, що, щоб прогодувати родину
я мушу братися за будь-яку роботу
коли на першому місці стоять гроші
а не те, чим я займаюся
Такого тиску вже немає
Корінна виграла свій
безумовний базовий дохід у лотерею
Німецька ініціатива "Мій базовий  дохід"
збирає гроші
шляхом краудфандінгу,
тобто через пожертви людей
Як тільки назбирується 12 тисяч євро
необхідні, щоб людна впродовж року могла
просто так отримувати тисячу євро щомісяця
базовий дохід розігрується між донорами
Наразі вже сто  шістдесят сім людей
виграли в лотерею
"Мій базовий дохід"
Проте для ініціаторів це - більше ніж просто лотерея
На їхню думку, концепція базового доходу може ефективно функціонувати
на рівні держави і допомогти впоратися
зі змінами на ринку праці в майбутньому
Ми бачимо, що цифрова епоха змінює майже все
як ми працюємо, як функціонує наша система охорони здоров’я, мобільність тощо
Лише державна соціальна система
залишається незмінною
Тож, безумовний базовий дохід, як на мене
міг би стати належним розвитком соціальної держави
модель якої походить ще з 20-го століття
Через перехід економіки на цифрові технології
через розвиток штучного інтелекту лише в Німеччині
можуть бути втрачені сотні тисяч робочих місць
Передусім це торкнеться людей
з низьким рівнем освіти
За прогнозами експертів, це стане величезним навантаження для соціальної системи країни
Та чи є безумовний базовий дохід
правильним шляхом?
Економіст Юрґен Шупп так не вважає.
На його думку, це занадто дорого
Ми знаємо, що лише фінансування базового доходу
який нині дискутується
байдуже чи то 1000 євро чи 1500
якщо виплачувати це всім громадянам Німеччини
то лише на ці виплати піде третина нашого ВВП
Ми будемо змушені збільшувати податкові надходження
порівняно з тими, що маємо зараз
Корінна вклала свій річний
базовий дохід в потрібну справу
інвестуючи гроші та час у професійну освіту
Проект став для неї гарним стимулом для розвитку
Нині такі експерименти проводяться
й у інших країнах
Але знадобиться більше часу
аби зрозуміти, чи підійде
ця модель суспільству загалом